Speaker 1: Let's hear from the most
important people in the world. For
The David Pakman Show it is our audience. We
take calls occasionally via discord. You can
find our discord at David Pakman dot com
slash discord. And we're going to start
today with a very important person. Mr.
Rogers in Atlanta, Georgia. Mr. Rogers,
welcome. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 5: Hey, Dave, welcome to my neighborhood.
I just wanted to ask I'm having difficulty, I
guess you'd say, reaching out to members, I would
say across the aisle about the Herschel Walker and
all my campaign. Okay. I have a lot of neighbors
that just want to vote for vote for Herschel
because he was a damn good dog. And I mean,
as a native Georgian, I understand that and I
get that. But I'm like trying to talk to these
guys about how, you know, he's definitely not
a good representation of what it means to be
a Georgian or a southern belle these days.
Speaker 1: And so I wanted you to help me
understand that. And this is interesting
because you're you're talking to these
folks. Herschel Walker is completely unable to
explain his position on even a single issue.
How do these people that like him do do they
not even care what his positions are? Do they
pretend like they understand what his positions
are? What how do they explain his incoherence?
Speaker 5: I mean, I try to say, like, you
know, I appreciate his time in football,
but his CTE is just not what we need. You know,
when it comes his positions, they say, you know,
it doesn't matter. You know, he's just Republican.
He's just going to vote Republican. And I'm like,
y'all worried about the war not being a Biden
boy? And I'm like, he's going to as soon as
Walker gets there, he's just going to be
a hero. Moscow, Mich. The fervor and he's
not going to do anything for these is going to
be told to vote and how to vote. Yeah. I mean,
it's obvious when you see his what he called
news conferences that Walker is about as Coates
as you can get on some of his background.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And still incoherent. Have
you heard from any folks about the
reaction now to the whole abortion
scandal? Do they care about this story or are
they calling it fake news or they don't care?
Speaker 5: I have one guy to talk to
on a regular. He says it's fake news.
Speaker 1: Oh, he just doesn't believe that.
Speaker 5: But another guy says, you know,
he says it's taken to court. So we'll see how
the dollars fly. Okay. You're willing to listen
to the court. But I'll be honest in this story
and I haven't had much time to talk to you.
Speaker 1: That's really depressing. Yeah.
Let let me ask you this. Are some of these
folks who support Walker, are they otherwise
normal, moderately intelligent people? Or are
there people who, if you probed their beliefs on
just about everything, are a little bit wacky?
Speaker 5: I'd say it's a mix of both
because, you know, you'd go down to the
bar for a football game there, commercials.
You talk to these people and we'll talk
normal stuff. But then all sudden it can
get a little odd sometimes. But yeah,
I'll be honest. It seems like most of the time
Georgia fans just want to vote for Herschel
because you're damn good dog.
Speaker 1: Okay. And what
do you mean, a damn good dog?
Speaker 5: Oh, I'm sorry, David. The
college football thing down here in the Southeast
United States. Damn good dog. As George is saying,
for any good. Particularly a good football player.
Oh, okay. But I myself am a damn good dog. I'm a
graduate of the University of Georgia myself. But
you get the damn good dog a, I guess, title if
you really show how just how good you are.
Speaker 1: All right. Very good. Is that
a bike train I hear in the background?
Speaker 5: Yeah, I apologize for that. My
windows are open. It's a nice day. Two days.
Speaker 1: Is that January? Did I
picture it? Actually is a bike chain.
Speaker 5: Yeah. Oh, wow. Hardly going.
Speaker 1: By. All right, that's it. Oh. Oh, oh,
right. Okay. I thought it was, like, a bye. Oh,
very good. All right, Mr. Rogers. Thank you.
Let's. Let's hope Warnock wins. You know,
let's. Let's let's hope.
Speaker 5: Indeed. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Thank you very much for the
call. There's Mr. Rogers in Atlanta,
making a number of very, very
important declarations there